here we go why didn't you know that um
good morning everyone um
so welcome to the legislative
administration we have a couple of uh
substitutes on our side thank you very
much representative mcguire and
representative folsom
i think there is
three or four
theoretically going to be here on
the democratic side
and we'll welcome them as they come
here comes the democratic
party now
welcome to the party
yeah
you are the democratic party at the
moment
that's it
um i know
of at least four others okay good
um
so the plan
from my standpoint is to take a look at
those bills that we have
scheduled on the calendar for work
session
cacr 24
hb
hb 1102 hb 1170 and hb 1269
in no particular order um
but i these are the ones that have been
pointed out to me as being
maybe needing work maybe
we can reach a consensus
easily or enough with an amendment or
something along those lines but i would
like to
then
slip into executive session
as you'll see executive session on
pending legislation may be held
throughout the day
from time to time the committee is
initially convened um
that is now um
so we are capable
of bringing up any of the bills that we
have held hearings on
and executing them
um
but we are scheduled now for the work
session are there any
is there any idea from
the members which
where where to jump into the work
session
you have
you have a time constraint so you may
want to yeah
three three one zero three three okay
um
yep we can do that
so um why don't we
without
without any objection
um bring up cacr 24 which is uh
regarding the attorney general and um
and providing that the attorney general
be elected by majority vote of the
members
of the general court
in a joint session
we do have
some
background information
that has been
i'm hoping has been distributed to
our
welcome
take your time welcome
glad you're here
um
that is
that's not the one csr24
um i did so you know i went through and
uh pulled out the
legislative
um
sign-in sheets the electronic sign-in
sheets so if if i don't remember someone
can remind me
but only two people
signed in in support
of cacr 24 and zero signed in opposed
we also
have an amendment that's on the floor um
from the prime sponsor uh
representative silber
um i assume every that was handed out at
the hearing so i'm assuming everyone has
taken a look at that
we also have some legislative history
from um
our researcher
i'm not sure if
if our
guests today have any of this you don't
have any of this
would you like us to make copies of this
so that you can
follow along and see where we are
i think so too
always a plus it doesn't work for us but
it might work
yes zero zero five eight h you have to
make sure that microphone is on so
people watching in their homes
yeah
so um
the existing amendment is zero zero five
eight h i'm going to grab the entire
section i have here and can you ask
heather if she will
make copies for
mr chair
yesterday
in the course of a conversation i heard
that there was a problem with the
boilerplate language
on all the constitutional amendments
uh were you aware of that
no
ah
on all of the ones that we have
apparently all the constitutional
amendments written this year have the
old boilerplate and not the new
boilerplate
and what does that mean
i'm not a lawyer
[Laughter]
i have not received any
memo or
any
that was a rumor you heard or it was a
report by from representative pearson
who is a sponsor of a constitutional
amendment and it was told that it had to
be fixed
and i don't know what the uh we do have
the majority leader in the room are you
aware of
we do also have the house clerk in the
in the room is that
is there anything to this could you
please
help us a little good morning
representative
good morning mr chair members of the
committee uh just to answer your
question
several years ago
statutory revisions were made with how
constitutional amendment concurrent
resolutions are drafted
basically what that means is that any
amendment that is drafted is going to
need an amendment by the committee
if it's going to be acted on positively
because essentially
you have to draft the language that's
going to be included in the um
the the the voters guide that's created
for voters so that that is that was a
reconstruction of statute about a decade
ago by then senator bragdon
uh thank you
will you take a question or two if there
are any certainly
so
i'm not seeing any but here's my
question um
my question is
it sounds like this is not anything
that's just new for this year this is
something that has been ongoing
that is correct sir every every time
we've had a a constitutional amendment
over the last several years if if
something is to pass the body it's going
to need an amendment created by the
committee to address the voter guide
issue
is that
having to be voted on prior to it
reaching the floor or is that something
that could be a floor amendment or
i i suppose a floor amendment
would handle that because again it would
have it would have the uh the action
included
okay
um
representative mcguire is that
your understanding more or less yes
fortunately my committee only had one
cacr and we voted to kill it
there is
on some of these however there are um
there is verbiage that says what
what the
voter guide language would be is that
sufficient or does that have to be
changed i think that the the the
boilerplate as representative mcguire uh
alluded to uh is that it hasn't
necessarily been there however if
sponsors of certain amendments have
gotten deep into the weeds to make sure
it's included then
then kudos to them
um one other question while i have you
on the hot seat okay
and and not necessarily with this cacr
but we have another one that could prove
to be
if if required to print out every
possible change
to something like the constitution
it was
mentioned in testimony by someone
that
the entire constitution
would need to be in the voter guide
because you need to show the voters
every single change
that is correct
correct yes
i wanted to clarify that
that's a good reason to kill that one
i think i concur
um that would make the vote yes that
would make the voter guide
10 or 12 pages um just on that one
question i would think
could be an opportunity for education
um
yeah
um so anyway back on
on
cacr 24 um
there uh
we didn't pull this out and have copies
made for our
for our guest that um
well
those are my notes
no i think i have a clean one it's just
the front page for my notes
um
but at any rate uh so we have an
amendment um
the
to paraphrase or or my understanding and
people can correct me my understanding
of the amendment was just to simply put
um
the
the exact language but into a different
section of the law
it was in one section of law that didn't
that was different
for purposes of voting
than what we currently do when we
when the house
and senate votes for in joint session
for secretary of state and um
treasurer
and all that the amendment did was bring
this attorney general new language into
that same section so that there would be
an election
handled the same way that we that we
currently handle it for the secretary of
state and treasurer
i don't think there was anything else in
there besides that
now that i don't have my uh my guide um
are there any things
oh thank you are there any things in the
uh in
our researchers guide that
anyone would like to
or is there are there concerns with this
are we good with it as it is are we yep
yes
am not going to support this
uh from research that i was able to do
i found that in the past 41 years there
have been 20
attempts
to change the provisions of our
constitution
regarding the attorney general
my personal belief is that
our constitution is a sacred document
it's the basis on which we have
lived and performed all our duties for
hundreds of years
and before anybody goes to change the
constitution there should be an effort
to find out what the real need is
and perhaps file bills
to determine those needs and to
determine what direction in which we
should go
um
every single time
provision has come through
to change and elect
the attorney general it has gone down
therefore i i cannot support
this cacr
thank you representative
there are um
in some of the
emails i've received um
they did mention the 19 or 20 times and
and our researcher brought up the 19 or
20 times
as you go through
you see that
about half of those
there is a request for the entire state
to elect the attorney general
and about half of them
there is a request by the just the
general court to elect like we do with
the secretary of state
um
the other thing that occurred to me as i
was looking through the researchers
write-up
with 19
with 19 attempts at this
that to me indicates that there's a
concern um or that in and of itself
means that somebody is
is thinking enough about this that there
has that it keeps coming back um it's
not just one and
done
so um that was that was my view of
um why it
at least
deserves some additional
attention that's all
anyone
seeing none
i think we
i i don't
suggest that there is
any any type of amendment or anything
that we need that we could work on
there's nothing about this
that you find favorable
um
there's no
where are you i guess
aside from just saying no i'm not
um well it's not just yeah okay it's
years of experience in listening to
members of the general public and
members of the general court
and yes there are people who have
obviously brought this issue forward
multiple times
and i i don't see anything wrong with
the way it's drafted it's the concept
and the fact that if we start
trying to elect our attorney general
what is the best method shouldn't we
figure something out before just saying
we're going to do it
um
when you're building a house you lay the
foundation there's no foundation for
this except we want to do this we want
to change the constitution
again as i said earlier it's important
to look at an issue and if there is a
real need from the general public in the
general court then we should study it
figure it out figure how to do it what
the best method is
so that we don't politicize this office
too much and so that we don't cause a
lot of confusion and
hold things up in a process that
currently works
anyone
representative wallace thank you mr
chairman seeing that this has come up 19
or 20 times for a change over the last
40 years it makes me wonder what
happened roughly
40 years ago
to initiate these requests for changes
something must have occurred
as a trigger to
make this change
i don't have that answer but i have the
question
um
you know if you go back and read
some of the
testimony and the history from those
times that
has come up it seems like
it's a different a different issue each
time as i read it
um
there are there are some it
and it truly has been studied because
they talk about whether it should be a
position that's four years rather than
two years
they talk about obviously whether it
should be elected by the entire
population or whether it should be
just uh from the house side in the
senate side and joint session
so there are
conversations i think where
if you boil it down
as i look at it it seems that it comes
from a concern
that
in its current state
um
the attorney general is a
function of the executive branch
and
and there are two part
parts or two problems with that seen by
the people the drafters
one is
if there is an issue
that
is involving the governor
they wonder whether there's a conflict
of interest and whether the attorney
general will not aggressively pursue
that issue because they are
part of the executive branch and that is
you know it's like taking on your boss
so that's one
avenue one problem the other problem
that they see is that
it is
the attorney general is there to defend
the laws that the general court
creates
so there needs these people that that
draft
the amendments in in prior years have
said then the attorney general needs to
be have a direct
link to the general court so that they
would defend their
their actions
rather than the executive branch
those are the two that i see
that's that's just my reading
representative
thank you
um we were given information
by the sponsor in an attachment and
it when i read through this
it appears that though there were 43
states that elect the attorney general
by popular vote
but the amendments that had been brought
forward
really were to
elect
by the house
and senate
and
that
has been the times that have been
not passed by the house died on the
floor of the house we're a retaining
committee
there's and the 43 states elect by
popular vote there's only one state
that does it
by the house and the senate and that's
the state of maine
so with that it appears that the
majority of the states in the country
don't seem to have a problem with the
current way that it is
so
i am um
flip and flopping on this one
thanks
uh yes representative i i'm sorry i i
don't have a list that you are um i'm on
this committee
oh
i i apologize that we have not yet met
uh representative schultz from concord
it's uh lovely to be here i'm sorry that
i wasn't here
in person for the hearings but i did
diligently watch them
and um
i didn't know if i was going to bring
this up but why not i actually have
worked for attorneys general and other
states actually just one other state
kentucky where i'm from originally
where they elect many
positions
and um
i would support
the people of the granite state choosing
an attorney general because
i think that gives the general public
an enormous chance to vet issues around
judicial
authority
many issues are raised on the campaign
trail
there
i am proud to be a granite stater and i
realize we don't have a lot of
statewide elections but i would support
for whatever it's worth
electing
more
uh executive branch officers at the
state level
and i happen to have worked for two
attorneys general
for whatever that's worth
thank you representative
yes
thank you mr chairman um i'm guessing
that there are members here today who
have not been familiar with this issue
before and in terms of how we get our
attorney general in the first place
as with other positions
the governor does not choose the
attorney general the governor
makes a nomination
it's a selective process and then the
executive council votes on this
my concern is that if we have the house
and senate vote on the attorney general
becomes too politicized
the attorney general is not responsible
for answering to us as people
the attorney general is responsible for
dealing with laws and protecting our
state from criminal activities
the concern that we've heard in the past
is that if we elect our attorney general
then if it's for two years or four years
or whatever length of time that's chosen
it becomes too political because that
person then has to raise money has to go
out and get elected campaigning and such
and what happens if there's a big
criminal case just before an election we
have to trust that our attorney general
is going to focus exclusively on that
case and not on getting re-elected and
there is the potential for conflict of
interest
um and again
um
i i'm deeply concerned
that
a process that's working now
would be changed and become so
politicized and complicated as opposed
to something that's working right now
and again the old axiom if it's not
broken don't fix it
thank you
anyone
um
i think we've taken everything we can
out of that um
it may be
maybe that our best move at this point
is to move on to one of the the other
items
next on the list is
house bill and i realize you've just
received your packet so
i
i hesitate to
make you smarter by giving you all that
and then not giving you the time to read
it so that kind of
makes it
difficult she needs to sign in too right
um
i think we also should probably uh try
to create the packages for
the other bills that we have
because we'll run into the same problem
so why don't we uh take just a quick
second and
and assemble those
um
at least provide
the researcher
uh so
on 10 10 33 this is
this is prohibiting
recipients of state or local grants or
appropriations from using such funds for
lobbying
um
there is also an amendment on this bill
that i'm trying
you have a copy of that from
oh redo right here here's already made
out
half that way
uh this is from
has my name on it as well as uh the
prime sponsor um
what
what happened in this bill
was um
when ols drafted
there is a current law
rsa 15 colon 5
that prohibits recipients of state or
local grants
from using state funds for lobbying and
when the prime sponsor went to ols
they simply use the same language
in order to
create
the prohibition on using
local funds for lobbying as well
and
there was some question
during the hearings whether that was
appropriate to use the language of grant
or appropriation of state county
municipal
school district and village funds
so this amendment changes
or adds a line
to further define
that
those
funds refer to
funds raised by local property taxation
so the purpose of the bill
is
to enhance the existing 15 colon 5
legislation
so that state funds would not be used to
hire professional lobbyists
and
local property tax funds would not be
allowed to be used to hire
professional lobbying firms
where are we on that on this
legislation
representative roulard
thank you
um for the folks that just got that
amendment there's a paragraph two to it
and it just reiterates
county municipal village district
throughout that section as well
the questions that i have for this is
when we're talking about recipient
this particular statute is the statute
for lobbying
and when we talk about recipient
i'm just not sure how that is defined
and i don't know if it is defined as a
lobbyist
a
individual that is paid
funds
by the town or municipality that they
are
in
maybe the clerk
or a school board
director
a
anybody else i'm not sure recipient what
that really means
in grant or appropriation
i'm also concerned a little bit that we
have grant or appropriation of the state
or the county
and the reason that that
is a concern of mine is grants have a
tendency to have funds that are not
necessarily
from state tax dollars and you could
have grant money and sometimes
commingled
with
funds that have been donated as well as
funds from the state and there's nothing
in here
to indicate how that is going to be told
to the person that is the recipient
of as to whether or not there is any
funds that is just grant money
um
that's given to the towns or or the
village districts so i think that we
probably need to kind of tune that up a
little bit
and
because if we have a recipient
that
would be prohibited
to participate on line five in political
activity
i'm just not sure what that means does
that mean
that they are unable to speak to
their state representatives or their
senators or
go out and pick it
whatever it is we're voting on i i just
don't know so i think that there needs
to be a little bit more definition there
especially when we're dealing with funds
from the municipality and the village
district etc so although i would i am
in support
of lobbying and um
funds coming from taxpayers for lobbying
purposes i think the language needs to
be perhaps looked at a little closer
thank you
can i clarify one thing you asked sure
um did did you say that you were in
favor of funds coming from property
taxes
for lobbying purposes
no i'm not in favor
i left out the word not did i no okay i
am not in favor
um
there is also uh section 15 colon one um
that determines
who who is a lobbyist and and
um it was pointed out to me by um
i think it might have been been pointed
out by one of the people testifying
um that lobbying
public
they're following i'll read the section
v
um the following or roman five i guess
the following communications are
excluded from the regulation imposed by
this chapter and shall not be considered
any determination of whether a person is
required to register and report as a
lobbyist
and a is public testimony before a
legislative committee or subcommittee
so it would seem to me
we heard testimony that this would
prohibit
cities and towns to have their voices
heard
by the general court and i think this
points out that that
that would not be the case there there
would still be testimony allowed
yep
representative roulette all right thank
you i think that where we're in the
lobbyist section
um and we're talking about lobbyists
being prohibited
that when we talk about no recipient
of a grant perhaps me we want to
consider no lobbyists
where that's in the lobbyist section so
there's no ambiguity those are just my
thoughts
is that a hand raised
thank you mr chairman um after we had
our hearing i heard from two communities
both smaller towns
one's medium-sized ones very small and
we heard from the municipal association
the municipal association comes before
this committee and others
in the legislature and essentially
lobbies
if you would put it that way for issues
that affect municipalities in the
state
there is a concern
that i have heard
after our hearing
that this
would cause problems for cities
and towns because again as our chairman
said
they want to have their voices heard up
here what small town can afford to hire
somebody to keep track of all the bills
that come before us
and and figure out what's going to
affect the town and what isn't and then
take the time to come up here to testify
what city which is so busy with
budgeting and of all the concerns of any
big city is going to be able to do the
same and that's why we rely on the
municipal association we did have some
testimony which i think is a little
inaccurate something about how it cost
i could be wrong five thousand a year
for that
that was from
and that that is not entirely accurate
different municipalities pay different
amounts into that that was from that
particular town i think okay because um
one of the towns i represent just pays a
few hundred dollars a year to the
municipal association um so it does vary
according to population apparently
that's what we're figuring i think they
gave a range did they not uh they said
manchester was
big some number and
exactly yeah exactly so again the
concerns that i heard after our hearing
are that
um
some group like the municipal
association is essential
uh to come in and speak on behalf of
communities that doesn't mean all the
communities they're representing just
will agree with the municipal
association's position
but at least they're out there giving
information
to help the communities know
where others are standing there there's
just no way you can get all these
municipalities together to communicate
otherwise
so um i i did hear concerns about this
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative um do you understand that
the bill
would prohibit
a city in town from hiring
the new hampshire municipal association
is that what how you read the
legislation
mr chairman that is how the
municipalities who got in touch with me
interpreted it
and
um
it's not only the municipal association
but any other
lobbyists who might be out there for a
group unlike uh for example for
municipal insurances and things like
that
these communities who contacted me
believe
that what we have once again is working
there seems to be an
a concern among some legislators that
lobbyists are not altogether the kind of
people we really want to work with and i
apologize for putting it that way
lobbyists are here to inform us
lobbyists are here to work with us
if any lobbyist does anything that's
inappropriate the war gets out fast and
they don't have a job for long
we we have to rely on lobbyists for
certain matters
and at least they're there to inform us
we can listen or not listen but the fact
that we have them working for and with
us and
i don't know if
and i could be wrong but for my time up
here i've never heard of a lobbyist
who was hired just by
one town to promote one issue
and use taxpayers money
all lobbyists have to register all
obvious have to file accounts with the
secretary of state's office and so they
are accountable
and i don't see where there is a real
problem at this point nor do the
communities have contacted me thank you
very much
representative espidia
thank it was truman yeah i just
you know and i will i will say i don't
always agree with my my friends with the
orange badges all the time you know we
don't always have um sometimes we're in
opposition of each other but
i do think especially with um
you know i represented a large city like
nashua and
um i can imagine if you know if there
was a specific issue around like you
know land uh you know waste management
for example that
um would be something that i wouldn't
want my you know my my commission my
public works director to go all the way
take her time out of her day to go all
the way up to concord
um so that she would have to testify i
mean i think the municipal association
or sorry i shouldn't just even say one
group but other organizations like they
take the time to
to be able to do that and i do just
think that you know
that there is
you know funding for that does matter so
that these not just nashua but other
communities smaller smaller towns
that may not be able to afford it um
that they be able to have their voice
heard and conquered like i said because
of because of the hours that we serve
um
you know we're here at 10 a.m um 10 40
a.m right now if i was
you know in another career i would
probably be at work i'd be in the office
right now so it would be very difficult
for me to make the time to come up here
to
probably take some time off or i'd have
to be on the clock for work so that
would be taxpayer money from our
municipalities that would be going
towards our you know director to come up
here so that they could be speaking and
testifying on a bill that may negatively
impact or positively impact the
community so
i mean i see there is a lot of value
towards you know towards making sure
that um
that we could use you know funds in that
way so
thank you representative
representative simon thank you mr chair
um so i have a couple of thoughts i
suppose um
first off when we're looking at the fees
that the municipalities or the
municipality association is being um
given
by our local municipalities
if i'm correct when i'm reading this
amendment
we're only limiting funds given by
property tax correct so other funds are
available so when we're looking at a
town having to come up with 400 let's
say a small town in order to retain
those services
um they could get that through
fees that they collect at their
recycling center or any other place that
they get funds other than just from
property taxation
my other concern is that we're we appear
to be getting pigeonholed
into just talking about municipalities
school boards and things of that nature
but they're not the only organizations
that receive
these kinds of grants and appropriations
they aren't so specifically tied to
local representation of you know our
public our
political sector
and
would it be beneficial even potentially
to discuss
separating off municipalities in a
separate way if we had to from other
organizations that maybe get grants from
local funding um
because other kinds of organizations get
these funds so those are those are just
two thoughts that i have i
i i represent small towns all of my
towns are small towns um i find it hard
to believe with with the fees that
they're being charged that they wouldn't
be able to scrape together
the few hundred dollars that they would
need to outside of just
property taxation to retain those
services if they chose to thank you
thank you representative
any other comments
i think that um what representative
simon said is correct that um
that this is not a prohibition of of a
town whatever size
from hiring lobbyists i think this is
the source of the funds is the key item
whether and whether that would be still
available to them as an option
whether they have additional sources of
income
i also agree with the idea of
[Music]
of
i don't know if pigeonholing is the
right
phrase but um whether we are limiting
down and i and i think the purpose and i
shouldn't put words in any sponsor's
mouth but i think the purpose was more
for
the municipals and the municipalities
and the school districts
was where
in testimony he mostly spoke but
representative maguire
yes thank you this has come up several
times before
the usual
spur to putting a bill in like this is
the
school board association
coming in and fighting very hard for the
government school structure
which
looking at the sponsors
the the these people are are concerned
about
and they have been very effective so
the municipal association has also taken
stances that are
not always appreciated by members of the
house
and so this is an attempt to
just cut them off from public funds
because
those two organizations although they
are frequently very useful
do take very political stances on
occasion
and that's what this bill in my opinion
is intended to cut off that is the the
strongly political positions that they
take
on occasion
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for what you just said
you're absolutely accurate
as always
and um
but i i still am
i'm concerned that we're
taking too big a chunk out of
our
um
municipalities rights to have who they
want represent them in different cases
for different issues
and um i
i'm not altogether sure this bill is the
way to attack that particular problem
thank you
anyone
representative roulette
thank you i just want to make sure that
we get the wording of the bill correct
um
we have to be aware that in in the 50s
chapter 15 lobbyists there are penalties
for individuals that violate the statute
and criminal penalties and so we need to
make sure
who we're talking about
and if we're talking just about
recipients that may work in towns
that get funds
that's one thing if we're talking about
lobbyists
that's another
thanks sounds like an amendment coming
indeed
um with that um i think we've
covered enough of uh house bill 1033
i'd like to
open the conversation about
which i'm
also
not sure whether there is
ah
there is an amendment and that will be
we have copies yeah great
this um
this was a bill that appeared to need an
amendment um
while the prime sponsor was sitting at
the
at the witness table um
and so
[Music]
our vice chair has uh prepared the
amendment that is
coming around the purpose i think of
by the way there was only uh one person
signed in online in support of this bill
there were no none in opposition
the purpose of this
was to
remove
the boxing and wrestling commission from
within the
secretary of state's domain
um and and place it in
its own
rsa section
and that was it when we received the
bill however there were a number of
repeals that were tacked on to the
bottom that didn't appear to
be
necessary to the overall goal of the
prime sponsor
so this amendment that you have removes
the
original
language
of those three
repeals
and it removed one word
which happened to be the word each is
that right
yeah on line six
um
anyone have concerns representative
simon
i have no idea if it's a concern or not
but um line nine
attachment removed does anybody know
what that signifies on the amendment
carol repper maguires yes thank you that
it refers to the
administrative attachment of the boards
to the secretary of state the joint
board of licensure certification has
been
repealed for
four or five years
but it was previously administratively
attached to the
secretary of state
got it
thank you representative mcguire
anything else representative wall no
this media no
um
so it would seem to me that the
amendment should be
sufficient to
move along great
that was a simple one
like that um
hb 1170
was also one that seemed to have
concerns or or consternation or in need
of a uh an amendment
um
and this is limiting the authority of
the new hampshire delegates to policy
making
conventions
um
we do have an amendment i don't do i
see it in front of me
okay
representative wallace can you uh check
with
heather or somewhere
um
representative ruler you are aware of
what the changes were made though
correct can you give us a
line i am um
the changes to the underlying bill
were how the members of the delegation
were to be selected
it wasn't anything in the
bill to tell us that
um
so this amendment is number
uh
o270
h
and what it does
is in the first section of the bill
it says that four members of the
delegation
shall be selected by the new hampshire
house of representatives one member
appointed by the speaker the house of
representatives and three shall be
elected by a majority vote of the house
three members shall be selected by the
new hampshire senate one by
be appointed by the senate president and
two
members shall be selected by majority
vote of the senate so that clarified how
the members were going to be uh selected
the
second part of it there was a section in
uh section four of the underlying bill
that
did not really state how the members
were going to be paid and were not
defined there
and
this particular amendment says that
they'll be paid a hundred dollars a day
and reimbursed for actual expenses
submitted including but not limited to
lodging
transportation and meals
then the last section that was amended
in the bill is section three
and they talk about
the delegates from the state of new
hampshire to the convention
having to take an oath of of um
what their abilities are going to be
and
they changed the language a little bit
and removed some language in the on the
last sentence
and
the actual language reads now
i do solemnly swear or refer them to the
best of my abilities i will as a
delegate to the interstate convention
uphold the constitution and laws of the
united states and the state of new
hampshire i will accept and act in
accordance with the limits of the
authority as a delegate granted to me by
new hampshire under new hampshire law
and i will not vote to consider or
approve any unauthorized amendment or
policy proposal introduced by the
convention as prohibited by new
hampshire law and this is the language
that was changed this language now in
the amendment says i understand
penalties may be imposed under new
hampshire law for the violation of this
oath
the reason that that was important
is in the underlying bill
that last paragraph
actually
i can find it real quickly said i
understand and accept
any penalties
accepting the penalties in the statute
is in fact been removed so that you're
not able to put forward any defense and
they'll accept the penalties that come
so it's understand that penalties may be
imposed take away the i accept that's
what the amendment does
thank you representative um
any questions about the amendment we're
good
good good
all right
i think that's good thank you for your
summary it was excellent
um
what's that
you're welcome
um do you have anything to add since you
are a prime sponsor of the bill
not at this time
keep things rolling nicely done
um
the
last one on the list um for work session
is house bill 1269.
uh
this is a carryover or was purported to
be a carryover
from
a bill that was passed last year
relative to
removing
a certain defunct or inactive
study committees and
the house
passed a version
and
we sent it to the senate and the senate
did what the senate does and
changed it
and
remove some of our changes that we
specifically had put in
and
this bill happens to be the senate
version
that came back this year for us instead
of
the house version that we approved last
year
so
representative roulard has
and representative sheehan have taken it
upon themselves to
go through it with a fine-tooth comb and
are suggesting an amendment i believe
would either of you like to
comment representative ruler
i think since vanessa did the lion's
share of the work on this and a great
job she did she may wish to speak to
this
excellent representative
thank you mr chair
um i do have copies of the original bill
that that came to us um plus the
amendment that claire and i worked on
i can pass that out to you
go ahead
mr chair i just want to thank her for
including the original bill i really
appreciate that
you're welcome you're going to see all
my chicken scratch too in there but
well um
what representative roulard and i did
was we went
uh over the bill line by line comparing
it to
last year's bill that first came forth
and against the senate bill
and um
we worked through that
we
were in communications with one of the
the prime sponsor and the co-sponsor as
well as
the major change in the bill
um
was for the discovery center the christa
mcauliffe discovery center so we had the
director look through it too and there
was a lot of stuff in that section that
was obsolete so
if you um
can go through the bill we took
several things out
of the discovery center section
um changed a couple of words in there
there's a couple of typos we changed
um
and then as you work through the bill
and get to the end of the bill
we made some changes
uh we we met with uh clerk paul smith
and got his input
um
on the section about the committees of
committees and committees on committees
and uh we removed some of that section
taking out basically
the the new section of the bill that
came forth um added all this new stuff
at the very end of the bill so
we um can you tell us where it starts
where the yeah so
the the new stuff started um
at the
bottom of page eight
through the end of the bill
um we took out
basically
all of page 10
11 and 12.
um so why don't you give us line
lines on page eight you it starts where
um page page nine
the bottom of page eight yes uh lines
thirty
um
began the new section
the repeal of weights and measures
advisory board yes
so from there to the end of the bill was
totally
new additions
from the bill that we saw last year
and we worked through
page 9 in the top of page 10 with house
clerk paul smith and he gave us some
suggestions on wording
um
the the wording on on page 9
line 30 the codified study committee
um that wording should be commissioned
according to um
clerk smith so
we changed that wording
uh through um
page 10
line 10.
we kept that in
if you
the other
amendment we made was on page 10
line one
talks about 15 members
clerk smith suggested that we add that
the majority of those members should be
from the legislature
they should be legislative members
so we added that wording
on that
line and then
like i said
page 10 starting in line 11 to the end
of the bill
we totally took out
page 10
starting in line 11
through the end of the bill
page 12 line 22
the only
lines on page 12 we kept were lines 23
24 and 25.
and the amendment
that we wrote up
speaks to those changes now
once we
talked to ols about our amendment
and got that submitted we did
ref rouliard received a call from one of
the prime sponsors
wanting more changes
and um so
that's what we're here to talk about
today i don't know if you want to speak
to that representative roulard well
before we get there can i ask a couple
of quick questions about this so why um
we are repeal we we are
on line
eight
uh page eight line thirty three
um did we
remove
the weights and measures advisory board
and why
or is that still in there we did not
that's still in there
okay
you mentioned that that started the new
section um
on page 10 starting in on line 11. okay
but we kept the weights and measures
advisory board language
and each place that it says committee
you changed to commission yeah
and then uh what was the purpose of
removing everything from line 10
page 10 line 11. what what was
can somebody answer that for me
sorry uh because it was a joint
committee on codified study committees
it's a committee on committees
so
we felt that we didn't need necessarily
a committee on committees if we were
putting in a repeal
for both the codified study committees
and the commissions
to expire
five years from the date they were
effective
or
the date when they were complete and the
final report was issued whichever was
earlier
excuse me so that both
both types of committees the codified
and the commission
and why i have a fragment though
um will be repealed to me this is the
biggest thing in the entire bill
that these committees will expire
automatically
sunset and
with five years or after be when the
final report whichever is earlier so
that's the reason we didn't need that
last section because if you look at that
page and page 11 and 12. it talks about
the year beginning and then the other
night in 2024 and then it goes 25 and it
goes all the way through which is
uh kind of cumbersome rather than let's
establish the committees and the
commissions and that they will sunset in
five years
is that right vanessa
okay
further questions
representative
maguire yes thank you i don't know if
you covered this
but the
legislative information technology
oversight committee
um
where is that
page
two i think page one actually
that's
which should have been part of the
original
bill
that we passed last year right right
i'm glad to see you're getting rid of
the legislative committee but when i was
talking to the
the commissioner he suggested we might
add legislators to the
existing council i.t council
would this be an appropriate place to do
so or or not
page we're on page 10 in the underlying
bill with all the handwritten notes on
that
what page you want carol no page one i
was on page two
actually it's lines 23 24 25 are where
you're deleting the reference to the
legislative oversight committee because
the
looks like you're repealing that
somewhere else which is fine
no objection
but you're suggesting that we add
a legislator or two to the to that
earlier
in that section which describes the
council
excuse me
if it's too much if this is too
complicated i'll i'll skip oh no no this
is the time to do it yeah
and mr chair i think that's where where
is the um information
that designates how many people
or where they come from it's obviously
earlier in that section let me look it
up while you go on to other issues okay
but that should be i think that would be
the perfect time to add it into this
amendment
representative richard
uh thank you mr chair i just wanted to
clarify the explanation and also um
when
the word the codified study committee is
going away we're replacing that correct
the committee on committees essentially
is what this bill is doing on i'll tell
you la page nine um line 30.
right yeah we're changing yeah and
that's where the essential
essence of this right
and um uh representative ruler's
explanation was really
excellent with everything sun setting
but my question is is there anywhere
else
that maybe legislative services or you
did
looked for where
taking that this title of that codified
study committee
impacts
any other
legislation or is this the only place
where it impacts that or
did i understand correctly when
representative ruler said that means
everything else will sunset because
we've taken this away
i'm not sure that that's what i said but
i think that we have
the clerk of the house that can explain
why we wanted to make this change here
can we have the clerk come up and
explain why we did this
thank you mr chair members of the
committees so currently in statute we
have either study committees legislative
study committees or commissions the
original bill wanted to change the title
of commissions to codified study
committees my concern
is administratively
differentiating between committees as
study committees or chaptered study
committees versus codified statutory
committees or whatever uh iteration
there is so
the current practice of commission uh is
what what my suggestion was
i appreciate that explanation because i
was worried that
there was this had existed somewhere
else before but now we're making sure it
doesn't ever exist and that is a good
thing
okay thank you
right good
others
so we would expect more language coming
from
you representing actually looking at it
the
there are already two representatives on
uh the technology council and
i think that's quite enough
okay
we're good with that we're good with it
all right
representative
thank you mr chairman um
i appreciate all the work that's been
done and continues to be done on this
particular issue because we've heard
testimony and those of us who have been
here for a while know there's been a
proliferation of commissions and study
committees to the point where
they often dominate the work that we do
especially during the summer time so i i
am thankful for the work that's been
done
i think if we did nothing else this year
and passed this
we've earned her a hundred dollars
um
great
so that um i think that pretty much we
just have one correction or two or a few
uh we have um a few um
amending the amendment right um
but um so for exact session
when we bring this up we would be able
to have
the corrected version we're done now
we're not taking any more suggestions
right this is it we're done and i didn't
want to add that we
they took out a section about marine
fisheries
right
that
we heard from
some members of the marine fisheries
last year asking if we could
make a change and so we did and we
passed that last year and it was taken
out of this bill this year so we amended
it and put it back in that was another
amendment that was it just to remind
people
that marine fisheries was set up so that
it was an exclusive club to those that
lived on the seacoast you had to live in
a seacoast town to belong to the marine
fisheries
commission
and and we made it
we changed one word and said there would
be a majority of members that came from
that but not so that it wouldn't exclude
the possibility that someone happened to
move out of a seacoast town but still
was on that commission
and the senate ended up taking that out
um
i think the the club decided that that
was not not good so
i'm pleased to see that that's back in
here
right
and i think we now are sending them back
a better version of what we sent them
the first time
so let's see how that goes
um great i think
i think we're done with our work session
i'm going to suggest a
10 minute break and then we come back
and try to exact some of these um
we can do 15 minutes that's fine so mr
chairman yes
one quick question about
this
amendment to the bill
i i believe
did i hear correctly that um the
original sponsors
had a chance to see this amendment
and they were cool with it
i don't know
we had
i had conversation with um
representative umberger
about changes uh to this i'm assuming
that she also spoke with representative
ebel on that
she also had conversation with the folks
from the discovery center and went over
this line by line with me
so i did have changes to be made we put
them in so that the sponsors of the bill
are the ones that are actually driving
the train on this
thank you
i did receive an email from the prime
sponsor that said i have a conflict
tomorrow meaning today and won't be able
to attend the work session unless
something changes
ordinarily i would have been there in
case the committee needed me as a
resource i communicated with karen
though
representative umberger and she brought
me up to speed i'm happy to help as
needed so
if that helps your
question
i appreciate the time for answering that
thank you
all right uh we're on break till 10 30
and then
we'll start
exacting
you
okay we'll open the executive session um
and we'll begin
with uh our cacrs and just run right
down the list there will be three bills
that we will not take up for exact
session today
that would be house bill
house bill 1269
and house bill 1368
those we are
waiting for amendments or
or
small pieces of information so we'll
have one additional
short
exec session in the future
um
yes representative
so we only have one early bill maybe
maybe our clerk can tell us when the
deadline would be
are you
yeah
what's that
it's true of a different committee the
deadline for early bills is the tenth
right that and we only have
the one bill that's an early bill
the non-early bills when do you want
when do you need
march 10th
there you go
look at that
i had no idea ventriloquism was added to
the house clerk's uh
list of accomplishments that's pretty
good
um all right so uh
i would be entertaining a motion uh on
cacr13
and i would be looking to representative
wallace thank you mr chairman i move itl
on cacr 13.
representative wallace moves itl on
cacr13
would you like to speak to your motion
briefly
my three terms here no constituent has
ever mentioned legislative compensation
as an issue that impacts their lives as
such i must represent their interest and
leave it as is so i move itl
representative wallace moves itl is
there further discussion representative
expedia
you know at this time i think reducing
the pay to two cents would be
i think it's it's it's not the right
course of action um and i just think
that
given that we do have some expenditures
200 goes it goes a long way so just
against it
thank you representative speedy any
further discussion
seeing none i'll ask clerk to call the
roll
representative greene
yes
representative osborne
representative roulard yes
clerk vote cs
representative simon yes
representative folsom yes
representative wallace yes
representative mcguire yes
representative wall yes
representative telersky
yes
representative richards
representative gunning wong yes
representative espia yes
representative schultz
yes
representative hill yes
a little sticky note didn't help
zero
the count was 15 to zero c-a-c-r-i-t-l
yes you can can't you
yes
cac our clerk is saying yeah that was
news to me so
no that's great that's how we learn
um
so i hear no
disagreement with consent
consent it is
we'll move on to
cacr
if you give us a minute to
realign
you decide you you drive this bus
you're good
all right uh cacr
23 i'm looking for a motion
representative green mr chair i move itl
on cacr23
representative green moves itl on
cacr23 do i have a second
second from representative roulard
would you like to speak to your motion
representative greene
just briefly uh the testimony we heard
there's some very pragmatic reasons that
why this bill shouldn't go why it
shouldn't be going forward requiring
very long verbage on the actual ballots
for the voters
thank you representative greene any
further discussion on cacr 23
representative expedia thank you mr
chair um i'll i will be uh voting no on
the icl i believe that this uh
legislation has to merit i think that we
can you know i think that the
constitution does the purpose of
amendments or to keep our constitution a
living document to be you know
modernized with uh the current situation
of our state so you know i think this
would be a good a good bill to just
re
you know
change some of the verbiage um as you
know there's there's language around the
governor being he and and his royalness
and i think you know we've had a couple
of
female governors so i think that you
know changing the constitution to make
sure that the language is concerning
with the times would be would be would
be good
thank you representative expedia
any further
conversation on cacr23
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the roll representative green yes
representative osborne
representative roulard yes
clerk votes yes
representative simon yes
representative folsom yes
representative wallace yes
representative mcguire
representative wall no
representative tallersky no
representative nutting wong
no
representative richards no
representative espedia no
representative schultz no
representative hill yes
vote is nine six
itl motion passes
moving on to cacr 24
um i would uh
look for a motion from representative
wall
mr chairman i vote on remove rather on
cac 26 cacr
itl 24 24 i'm sorry
rookies
on cacr24itl
thank you representative wall moves itl
on c8
right
representative schultz
seconds
on cacr24
is there any would you like to speak to
your motion representative wall
thank you mr chairman during our work
session i was very vocal in terms of
why i want this to be killed i i believe
that the constitution is a sacred
document i don't believe that we should
just be changing it because there are
individuals who don't agree with the way
it's drafted it's not broken we don't
need to fix it if we were to elect the
attorney general we would be
politicizing the office
if we were to elect the attorney general
there's a concern that there might be a
conflict of interest if a serious case
came up just before election where would
the concentration of effort be with the
election or with the case there are all
kinds of concerns uh this just is not a
cacr that we should pass thank you
thank you representative wall any
further discussion representative
schultz
um i have a different reason for
what wishing for the same motion but um
i think she said her case well
great thanks very much representative
schultz um any further discussion
your microphone is on representative
wall
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the role
representative green yes
representative osborne
representative roulard yes
clerk votes yes
representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes
representative mcguire
yes
representative wall yes
representative tellerski yes
representative nutting wong
yes
representative richards
representative espedia yes
representative schultz
yes
representative hill
zero do i hear consent 15-0 sorry uh do
i hear consent
any
consent it is
thank you very much
give us a minute to reset
set
open the executive session on cacr
25 and i would ask representative
roulard for a motion
i move rto
representative roulard moves itl is
there a second representative wall
section
thank you mr chairman
would you like to speak to your motion
representative roulard
not really
um
um you don't have to i don't have to we
don't really need to
thanks
uh
representative wall would you like to
speak to your second thank you mr
chairman i have my hands our red book
that we were given each term there's a
whole page in here of representatives
who have served more than 15 terms
just because someone's been here a long
time doesn't mean that they're worn out
or ineffective
the voters determine who should come
back and who shouldn't if someone's
ineffective the voters determine that i
strongly believe that this is not a
necessary cacr thank you
thank you representative wall any
further discussion
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the role
representative greene yes representative
osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes
representative mcguire yes
representative wall yes
representative talersky yes
representative nottingham yes
representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz yes
representative hill yes
15 0 ito motion on cacr 25
passes do i hear
any
consent it is any objections seeing none
consent it is
reset for cacr
when the clerk is ready
clerk is ready
be looking for a motion from
representative schultz on
cacr26 thank you mr chair i move itl on
cacr 26. thank you representative
schultz uh is there a second
second from representative greene
cacr26
uh is moved itl
would you like to speak to your motion
sure
um while the sponsor of this
resolution
had creative and interesting thoughts
about the way we
represent
the granite state and
you know made some interesting points
for us to think about
but
the basic
premise within it regarding setting
aside
that number of reps and a different
sort of representation just really
seems impractical there weren't enough
provisions even if you support it to
fully determine how you would even carry
that out as an election so
that is why i moved itl
thank you representative schultz not to
mention you'd make everyone on the
redistricting committee furious for uh
you can add that into the blurb if you
would like
if there are
any other comments on
uh cacr 26 and the motion to ito
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
representative green yes representative
osborne
representative roulard yes clerk votes
yes representative simon yes
representative folsom yes
representative wallace yes
representative mcguire yes
representative wall yes
representative tallersky yes
representative nutting wong yes
representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz
yes representative hill
yes
15-0 do i hear any objection to consent
none
seeing none
it will be on the consent calendar
a minute to
reset
for cacr 27.
we're good cacr 27 i'm looking for a
motion from representative roulard
representative roulard moves itl on
cacr27
do i hear a second i second that mr
chairman second from representative wall
representative ruler would you like to
speak to your motion
thank you very much representative
roulearn
representative wall would you like to
speak to your second no sir
all of a sudden everyone has developed
bok choy
thank you very much any further comments
discussion people are hungry for lunch i
believe um
i will ask the clerk to call the role on
cacr27 which is an ito motion
representative green yes representative
osborne
representative roulard
clerk voties
representative simon yes
representative folsom yes
representative wallace yes
representative mcguire yes
representative wall yes
representative tallersky yes
representative nutting wong yes
representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz yes
representative hill yes
15-0 15-0
uh
would seem to be a logical candidate for
consent any objections to consent
seeing none
cacr 27 will be on the consent calendar
we will
hold up for a second
to reset for cacr cacr29
representative wallace you can get here
we're ready representative wallace i'm
looking for a motion on cacr29
imove cacr29itl
wallace moves itl on cacr 29. do we have
a second
thank you
representative wallace would you like to
speak to your motion
briefly again uh much like the cacr13
again it's not been an issue for any of
the constituents i've spoken to over the
last six years so
it's not needed at this time
will i tell this bill thank you
representative wallace as their
representative wall thank you mr
chairman i spoke with the prime sponsor
of this who recognized that this really
is not the way to approach the issue and
that he if he's elected and he expects
to be next term he'll come back with a
bill not with the cacr thank you
thank you representative wall any
further discussion on cacr
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
representative greene yes representative
osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes
representative mcguire
representative wall yes representative
tallersky yes
representative nutting wong
yes
representative richards
representative expedia yes
representative schultz yes
representative hill yes
15-0 are there any objections to consent
calendar
hearing none
cacr
29 will be on the consent calendar
just a minute for
reset
uh
represent uh for cacr 31
um
i would be looking for a motion from
representative nutting wong
yes i'd like to make a motion to it
lcacr31
representative netting wong
moves
itl on cacr31
is there a second representative
all second
up representative simon seconds
you're off the hook representative wall
um
yeah
representative netting wong would you
like to speak to your motion please
not really
representative netting wong politely
declines
representative
simon would you like to speak to your
emotional decline as well maybe not as
politely but she's pretty polite so yeah
i'm good
representative simon declines
yeah
represent uh so we are at um itl on
cacr31
[Music]
any further discussion representative
espidio would like this real quickly i'm
not against the idea of lowering the age
i think the issue is there are issues
with the bill and i just i think like
where you know we have to amend and it's
it's just not ready yet and so i'm we'll
be voting i tell you
thank you for your eloquent speech
representative
thank you very much
um
we
are ready i believe noah further
comments
the clerk may call the role
representative green yes
representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes
representative simon yes representative
folsom yes
representative wallace yes
representative mcguire
representative wall yes
representative tallersky yes
representative nutting wong yes
representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz no
representative hill yes
14 1.
we have no objection to consent
consent it is
cacr 33
is on deck
when we are ready
reset yep good
cacr 33
uh is up next and i am looking for
representative espedia to make a motion
uh yes i'm motioned to itl cacr33
representative expedia moves itl
is there a second well second
representative green seconds
representative expedia would you like to
speak to your motion i'm okay
eloquence went right out the door um
representative greene would you like to
comment
on your second no thank you
representative
green declines representative uh are
there any further discussion
comments
concerns none
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the roll representative green
yes representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes
representative mcguire yes
representative wall yes
representative telersky yes
representative nutting wong yes
representative richards
yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz
yes
representative hill yes
15-0 are there any objections to consent
on cacr
33 hearing none consent it is
moving into the house bills
when we get a second
you ready
our clerk is amazing
um
represent uh so we are house bill
1007 um
i would be looking for a motion from
representative simon thank you mr chair
i move itl on hb1007
representative simon moves itl on house
bill one zero zero seven is there a
second
all second
representative green seconds
would representative simon like to speak
to his motion uh briefly um there are a
number of things that are wrong with
this bill
but the vast majority of what is trying
to be done
is already covered under federal law
both in article 14 section 3 of the
united states constitution as well as
u.s code 2383
which already deals with the issue of
insurrection
or rebellion and would disqualify
anybody who
participated in those activities from
holding office at any level of
government within the state of new
hampshire whether it's local state or
federal uh so seeing as though the
federal government's already kind of got
that covered uh and the vagueness with
which we would have to
determine in our own body whether or not
somebody had um
was at fault
of participating in these activities uh
i'm move itl
representatives simon thank you very
much that's how it's done
[Music]
i would
ask if there's any further comment on
house bill 1007
oh sorry representative schultz
thank you mr chair
um
on january 6
2021 uh there was a resolution that we
had an opportunity to vote on
and it condemned the insurrection
seditious acts that were taking place in
our capital
i vividly heard
votes against that resolution
at the time our speaker did not hear
that and it was ruled unanimous
we have since heard instances of our
colleagues
expressing support in ways uh submitting
bills to secede from the united states i
think that this should be a bipart and
it is a bipartisan
opinion
that if you do not
support our electoral process
uh
campaigns are a replacement for violence
and violent overthrow of government
i don't think this should be
anything other than
a no-brainer i think
we have a lot of work to do as a country
i have concerns about bipartisanship
because of this topic
i believe in the good of all people
i think that
the right thing to do is to take a stand
that we even have to
say this is an issue is concerning
and i pray for peace
personally
and i hope that we can
find a way to move on from these issues
in a way that makes sense
but in our
in our court the general court i think
this bill
makes total sense and i
support
passing this bill
and um i say that
respectfully
um
i could say a lot more but i'll leave it
there
thank you for your comments
representative schultz well spoken
uh are there any other
comments to be made
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
representative greene yes
representative osborne
representative roulard yes
clerk votes yes
representative simon yes representative
folsom yes representative wallace yes
representative mcguire
representative wall no
representative talarsky no
representative nutting wong no
representative richards no
representative expedia no
representative schultz
oh no
representative hill yes
nine sixes the vote represent uh house
bill
1007 uh we'll go on the record as itl
i'm assuming there will be a minority
report yes sir and who will write that
i'm happy to representative schultz will
write the minority report
okay um
moving on to
[Music]
uh we're skipping um house bill 1033
we'll move to
uh house bill 104
and i would ask representative wallace
for a motion
uh i move
itl on house bill 1041. representative
wallace moves itl on house bill 1041 is
there a second
second
second by representative green
representative wallace would you like to
speak to your motion i'll pass
that was a no um
representative green would you like to
speak to your second oh thank you
ah
are there any representative schultz
thank you
if i had thought things through and
realized i was going to speak about this
topic i probably would have deferred
the last one to someone else um
but you know controversy is as it is um
i care deeply about this issue because
our non-partisan staff members have
suffered in the past couple years since
covid
protocols uh have been in place
i happen to know
um because i know at least one person
anyway from prior to my
being elected to this body
um
and
this person confided in me
and i've since talked to other of our
nonpartisan employees
that the way that they were recalled
to return to work the way that
protocols have been
flouted for lack of a better word in the
moment
some have worried for their own safety
and health
and
feel what you feel about labor unions
this gives an opportunity for workers to
come together and stand up for their
rights when they most need it
and to do
this in a non-partisan way is very
important
the oversight of our nonpartisan
employees
should be something that
helps all of them feel safe
that doesn't cause any of them to want
to
get a different job potentially we've
lost
some really good
staff members with enormous experience
and it is in large part because of the
way they have been treated as employees
i make no aspersions on any of the folks
who made those decisions
i get that there is a disagreement
but when it comes to
the health and safety
of the people who serve us and the state
i think that we have failed them
to give them the opportunity to stand up
for their own rights is the right thing
to do
and
why our country hasn't been as embracing
of the human right to organize
is
an issue that i care deeply about
um
and so for in the interest
of our employees
they deserve the chance to stand up for
themselves and not live in fear
of speaking out
for retribution because an issue seems
political
i think that is
morally wrong
and i am proud to be a co-sponsor of
this bill
thank you representative schultz uh any
further comments
i need to apologize to the group i um i
had in my head promised that i would um
report
the um
the online testimony uh either in
support or opposition to the bill
and i've neglected to do that
and no one told me about it so
this on this bill there was one person
that spoke in support which happened to
be a member of this committee um and
there were four people that spoke uh in
or testified no four people that signed
in in opposition to the bill
um
this bill uh just for your own
edification has been
here since 1998 one two three four five
six times
it has passed the house only once it has
passed the senate only once but in
different years
so
just just for your background
we have a motion on the floor of itl
is there any further discussion
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the role representative green
yes representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes
representative simon yes representative
folsom yes representative wallace yes
representative mcguire
representative wall no
representative tallerski no
representative nutting wong no
representative richards no
representative expedia no
representative schultz no
representative hill
yes
vote is nine
the itil motion passes
on house bill 1041
i am assuming there will be a minority
report yes correct representative
schultz
we'll
pen the motion append the minority
report
um
and that will obviously not go on
a couple minutes here while we
reset
and then we will start with
house bill 1083
we are good for house bill 1083
uh i will ask representative sheehan for
a motion
um i move itl
representative sheehan moves itl on
house bill 1083
is there a second from representative
wall thank you mr chairman i second that
seconded by representative wall uh
representative sheehan would you like to
speak to your motion
uh yeah
i moved to
itl on this bill because it's already in
process and being done so there's no
need for a bill
thank you representative sheehan
representative wall would you like to
speak to the motion no need to add
anything more it is already being done
thank you
i will only add that i think the prime
sponsor agreed and i think cheered as a
matter of fact when she
heard that it was being done and um and
i think asked for it to be
yeah
just just for consistency are you gonna
do the blue sheet on every bill now
going forward thank you you're welcome
um there were two people speaking in
support and one person um in uh no i'm
sorry nope nobody signed in in
opposition on the blue sheet
and and i'm not really sure
maybe
maybe we can get clarification of this
this is the online
um sign in testimony i don't think that
includes the blue sheet when i have no i
have no information from the blue sheet
just so
just so we're talking about the same
thing
yeah
um
yes representative isn't the blue sheet
in the folder for the bill
they don't do that that way anymore yeah
um
i have not seen
i've not seen a blue sheet
all year anymore
yeah
we have well
it may be
it may be that we didn't have any um
because remember we had almost no one
here other than the prime sponsor that
was here
but but i have no idea where they go
jennifer
with heather
but it doesn't get reported or
included in anything for the for the
clerk we don't
really
well um
up to you folks i mean it i
i
thought the only thing that i had to do
was go actually i didn't even have to do
that but i went online to try to find
out and i thought that there would be
more people online watching than than
not
but um but if you
want to add to this we certainly can go
get the folder for each one and do it
but it's up to you
okay great thank you very much
good talk
um
with that um i've lost my track we are
we have moved itl on um
108.3
um
no further discussion right and so the
clerk will call the roll
representative greene yes representative
osborne
representative roulard yes clerk voties
representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes representative mcguire
representative wall yes
representative tallersky yes
representative nutting wong yes
representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz yes
representative hill
yes
do i hear any objections to consent
seeing none
house bill 1083 will be on consent
we'll just take a minute to reset and
move on to house bill 1102 i will tell
you that one person signed
online
did i miss one
1084 sorry
ah that's right
1084 1084. um
i would uh on house bill 1084 there were
no people that signed in either
in favor or against
online
and i would ask representative green for
a motion
mr chair i move itl
representative green moves itl on house
bill 1084
1084 is there a second
second representative simon seconds
representative green would you like to
speak to your motion
yes um
in the discussion something i brought up
during the hearing is that
something i've
become more aware of
is
there's many instances where
a lobbying organization gets the idea
for the model legislation from a
legislator
i'm thinking this kind of sounds like a
what came first the chicken or the egg
so you can have this bill pass but
i think in reality
we really still don't really know
where
the impetus or where the true origin of
a bill is
and so that means for that reason i move
itl
thank you representative greene is there
any further discussion on
house bill
1084 representative expedia yeah so
you know i think
it would be great if in good faith like
people would say you know this bill came
from you know ex-group or you know
because i don't think you know we always
typically asked has this been done in
any other state which is you know it's
always good to know i was like oh how's
it going over in idaho or is it how's it
going over in nebraska um
but it is good to
i think for us to kind of get an idea of
if
you know if there were organizations or
um you know with particular interests
who who tried to help and it doesn't you
know i think it could be it sounds a
little
for some folks it'll be like oh well we
don't want folks to know that we didn't
come up with these ideas because i know
that a lot of us have great ideas but um
i think it's um i just think it serves
as a good way for us to know that um you
know legislation has been done in other
places that you know that the general
public knows that all right this is this
is where we got an idea from it so
that's why i'll
be voting um against the uh idea thank
you representatives media representative
mcguire
yes thank you i've frequently seen
legislation drafted by
professional organizations
brought in
as
a bill a
house bill here to
encourage
licensing for a profession that's not
currently licensed in fact there's been
quite a few cases
and
most of the time the sponsors
will mention that that this is you know
it was my idea to go for a license but
the language came from
the art therapist a professional
organization or
whomever
and so
it's very helpful to know that
information but i would agree with
representative espicia that it's
generally our idea we say we want to
to do this
and then we find out other places where
we can
get detailed language that saves us and
our
our hard-working
office of legislative services working
out the details of the language if
you've got a framework
to work from it's much easier to work to
present a well thought out build than if
you just say
i've got an idea
and
you know plop
so
i i think it's a good idea but i don't
know that it would be
appropriate to mandate it
thank you representative mcguire
any further comments
on house bill 1084
representative osborne
sorry i i apologize for not being
entirely familiar with this bill i'm
curious so i've had the constituents
bring legislation to me to have filed
for them
people who were afraid of retribution
from their employers
or from
regulatory agencies would this bill
preclude
them from being able to do so without me
having to name them
just wondering uh thank you for your
question um
i don't believe so
um
i think uh follow it as the bill says
following introduction of the bill if
the source of the model act
was not made available under paragraph
one a third party may request the
disclosure
but i think they're specifically talking
about the source of a model act
rather than
a
individual that gave you the idea for a
bill if that's what you're
referring to that you would not have to
disclose
that
the idea came from an individual it
would have to be from
from an existing model act
that answer your question or no
yes
sorry model legislation is defined
it's a legislative proposal or a uniform
or suggested act written promoted or
distributed by a partnership firm
non-profit entity or corporation to an
elected official into other public
officials of at least one more state and
then formally adopted is also defined
and according to this bill it means that
the partnership firm nonprofit entity or
corporation
votes to endorse support or distribute
the model act for legislative adoption
nope no that's hard that's why we're
here representative schultz
thank you mr chair um i want to just
hang a lantern on
the intent
behind the bill because
um
famous organizations like alec have
provided a number of bill language to
our colleagues
and i find it helpful to know if that's
the source but
just yesterday i was asked by a reporter
on an immigration bill
if that language came from an
organization that is declared by the
southern poverty law center
to be a hate group
you may know the group fair
you may disagree with the southern
poverty law center
but it would be helpful to know
because the implication is
that
certain anti-immigration bills that have
come through the house are actually from
this very well-funded organization
i think our constituents
deserve to know and
you probably could point out
organizations on our side that you would
like to know about too
i think that it's a reasonable request
and that a reporter asked me
is i think meaningful i suggested she
talked to the sponsors but for whatever
it's worth
thank you representative schultz
any further comments
seeing none
ask the clerk to call the roll
representative green yes
representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk voties
representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes representative mcguire
representative wall no
representative tallersky no
representative nutting wong no
representative richards no
representative expedia no
representative schultz no
representative hill
yes
nine six
nine the vote is nine six uh for itl
uh
that closes house bill 1084 i'm assuming
there's going to be a minority report
and who will write that
happy to unless another
representative expedia
thank you
um
moving on to now house bill
and we'll talk really
slowly
so we're good
moving on to house bill
um
and i would entertain a motion from
representative greene
thank you
representative greene moves out to pass
is there a second
representative wallace
seconds
on house bill 1102
representative greene
i understand you have a motion i mean
i'm sorry an amendment uh would you like
to
offer that amendment
yes this is amendment 0188h
the pro
before you do
zero one eight eight h uh we should all
have zero one eight eight h is that
correct
um
would you like to speak to what the
amendment does for us yes briefly like
the uh the prime sponsor said this is
mainly a
the bill itself's the house you can go
but the amendment it takes um
it takes out one word
from line five or six uh there's a word
each so the
words start with line five commissions
and boards functioning within the
department about law commissions shall
function within the department
and you have the strike through the word
each
in addition um
from the bill
there is some mention of
certain
commissions or committees that were
repealed they're really not germane to
what we're discussing here so we have
that removed in the amendment
that's pretty much it
thank you representative greene are
there any other comments on the
amendment
2022-10188h
i'll ask the clerk to call the roll on
the amendment to house bill 1102
representative greene yes
representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes
uh representative simon yes
representative folsom yes
representative wallace yes
representative mcguire
representative wall yes
representative tallersky yes
representative nutting wong yes
representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz yes
yes
uh amendment
2022-1
[Music]
0-1-8-8-h passes
we're now onto
ought to pass as amended on house bill
uh representative greene would you like
to speak to the motion
uh no i'm agreed no thank you
representative
wallace did you make a second on that
yes
comments
none
anyone like to speak to
house bill 1102 as amended
seeing none oh i'm sorry representative
folsom your microphone's on i didn't
know if that
that's fine
i thought you were indicating a
willingness
um seeing none i'll ask the clerk to
call the roll representative greene yes
representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes representative mcguire
representative wall
representative tallersky no
representative nutting wong no
representative richards
no
representative expedia
representative schultz no
representative hill
yes
house bill 1102 passes nine votes
to six as amended
i'm assuming or i shouldn't will there
be a minority report
we don't know
no
okay no minority reports
and i'll go in the regular calendar
house bill 1104
um
representative greene um i'm looking for
a motion
mr chair i move
itl
uh representative green moves itl on
house bill 1104
is there a second
hold a second
representative simon
representative simon seconds 1104.
representative greene would you like to
speak to your motion no thank you
representative simon would you like to
speak to the motion briefly the prime
sponsor filed this bill
um a few months prior to our last
meeting at the doubletree for a general
session
at that time we suspended the rules and
basically took care of this issue so
it's no longer necessary
representative expedia
yes so i
yes uh thank you mr chair and and and
thank you to representative simon for
that i think you know it was handled for
for this you know biennium i think we
need legislation that would
um you know just in case we had any
other circumstances where we would have
to change the state uh
the state house that we would have to
move
then we would you know it would be good
to be able to change that so
and be able to pay travel alone so
go ahead
all set
representative roulard
um i just want to clarify maybe i'm out
to lunch which i'm tired today but um
don't we have to
move to suspend the rules each and every
time unless it's actually in there paul
smith is shaking his head no
okay just wanted to clarify that thank
you thank you
representative mcguire actually it's a
question didn't
in that session of the doubletree we
passed house bill 1650 that said we
could pay mileage to wherever the house
was meeting
or am i mistaken
no that's correct you're absolutely
right representative mcguire it wasn't
the rules change it was the bill that we
late introduced
and voted on immediately that would
solve the problem that's correct great
thank you
representative wall did i see your hand
or no
no
representative ruler no thank you um
because i was unable to attend that uh
session i appreciate uh representative
mcguire's clarification
she stands thanks
we're good
any further discussion on house bill
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the rule representative green yes
representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes
representative mcguire yes
representative wall no
representative talersky no
representative nutting wong
no
representative richards
representative expedia no representative
schultz no
representative hill
yes
9 6
9 6.
itl motion passes
will there be a minority report
yes
expedia
um
noontime here folks um
what what's your pleasure um
we have
uh let's see that was eleven zero four
right so we have one two three
four
five six
seven
plow on or
just get them
just go
okay
11 house bill 1129
[Music]
this was uh
we good
okay i thought i did something um house
bill 11 29
um
you're all set
you're set
um
i would be asking representative ruler
for a motion
thank you mr chair i move ito
um representative roulard moves itl
second by representative
wallace um would you represent ruler
would you like to speak to your motion
not at this time thank you
representative wallace would you like to
speak to the second
i will tell everyone that this bill had
a zero
number of people signing in online in
support and one person signing in in
opposition
um
are there any further discussion on
house bill 1129
representative expedia thank you mr
chair um you know this bill is just uh
something that the
house has kind of gone back and forth on
um in terms of the fiscal committee
um
and you know i know that representative
ruler you've mentioned this before in
the past of uh you know it would be well
sorry i'm not gonna put words in your
mouth but i
i think
from my perspective we want to make sure
that you know if we switch back and
forth no we don't just you know i don't
think that the democratic or republican
party is gonna you know have a
stronghold over
um over who's in charge of the state
house for forever but um you know i
think it would be fair to be able to you
know have the fiscal committee be
um have a set number of folks um and
then also
have um the members be chosen by the
minority leader rather than
the speaker um
and so because i think they know their
their party well we hope they know their
party best um and so i think this bill
would you know would be a good a good
idea for for the future
so
that's why i will be voting now on the
ital
thank you representatives media
representative wall
thank you mr chairman and i just want to
reiterate that i think this is a good
bill it balances the committee
regardless of who's in the minority and
who's in the majority and i think it's a
good precedent thank you
thank you representative wall
i will just say in the idea that i've
heard earlier today that um
if it ain't broke don't fix um i think i
will be supporting the itl motion um
with that i will ask the clerk to call
the roll
on house bill 1129
with an ito motion
representative green yes
representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes
representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes representative mcguire yes
representative wall no
representative tallersky no
representative nutting wong no
representative richards no
representative expedia no
representative schultz no
representative hill
yes
knew you were gonna say that
um the itl motion passes nine votes to
six
will there be a minority report
yes and who will write that
expedia
representative expedia will write the
minority report
this is just so i know who to chase down
and that wraps it up
um moving on to uh house bill 1154
are you
ready to go
house bill 1154 had one person signed in
in support welcome representative
horrigan uh no people
signed in in opposition to it
we did have a
a comment from the prime sponsor i
believe um
but uh
i will be looking for
a motion from representative sheehan
um i moved to ito
representative sheehan moves itl um is
there
a second representative wall seconds
on house bill
any further would you like to speak to
your motion representative sheehan not
at this time thank you representative
wall you wouldn't prime sponsors exact
comments where it's not ready for prime
time
the uh
the nicest words used in the legislature
are we uh ready
to vote are there any further discussion
hearing none
i will ask the clerk to call the roll
house bill 1154 ito
representative green yes
representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes
representative simon yes representative
folsom yes representative wallace yes
representative mcguire
representative wall yes
representative tallersky yes
representative horgan uh yes
representative notting wong yes
representative richards yes
representative expedia
yes
representative schultz
representative hill
yes
16 0
ito motion passes do i hear any
objections to consent
no
consent it is
back on track
um
let the clerk
reset
and then we'll be moving on to house
bill 1170.
i should tell you uh house bill 1170 had
two people signed in support one person
signed in opposition online
and with that i will ask representative
wallace for a motion
thank you mr chairman i'm uh i move out
to pass an offer amendment
two zero two two dash
wait
all right ought to pass for
representative wallace is there a second
representative green seconds
representative wallace i understand you
have an amendment would you like to
offer amendment number
2022-02708
representative wallace offers
amendment 2022-027
zero h
that is correct
i need to second the amendment right
don't i no
no first right
we're good uh would you like to speak to
the motion to the amendment please
yes thank you um
during the public hearing there were a
couple of issues that were identified uh
by the members of the committee they've
been addressed um in
detailed fashion with the amendment uh
we've discussed that earlier and it
appears to be have addressed all the
issues that we identified
thank you uh
representative
oregon would you like to speak to them i
apologize for being late i
was i was at a another meeting the i
actually have not seen the amendment but
i've seen a lot of these bills and i
these articles from five conventions or
these other interstate conventions they
will be
function like legislative bodies just
like this house or the us congress
they'll set their own rules there'll be
some sort of enabling act that says how
many
delegates we have so certainly what's in
the bill is introduced
has nothing
has nothing to do with necessary to do
with what the parameters for any future
convention are so i i
feel silly breezing in here and then
saying this but i think this uh
i think this bill is off on the wrong
track altogether and we should probably
if there is any such convention of
course new hampshire should participate
but we will probably have to participate
representative we're talking about the
amendment at the moment not not the bill
okay what to see
if i can get you the amendment yes
please do okay okay so does anyone have
an extra copy for the for the amendment
is there any other
comments
concerns questions about the amendment
representative harrigan yes i see at
least one of my concerns has not yet
been met which was there we're deciding
how many members are in our delegation
and that's uh
that's
not necessarily going to be the number
of members we have in any such
convention and we would have to
pass and we would
we would have to pass another we would
have to amend the law or pass another
enabling act in order to participate but
um
and also these things
i've seen the part three um
we're worried about an unauthorized
using the constitutional amendment
anything that comes out of these
conventions would have to
be ratified by the states or ratified in
some other ways so anything
and there's a there's a very difficult
super majority it's very hard to get a
constitutional amendment passed so
anything any authorized amendment would
have no effect unless it actually got
ratified and if it got ratified my
belief is
it would be
something very popular that had broad
popular support here in new hampshire
and nationwide and
we
would probably be taking a political
risk and
blocking its ratification and
overturning the will of the people so
that's that's just my opinion today
thank you representative horror again
thank you for your patience mr chair so
that's why i'm here um
is there any other discussion on the
amendment
i see representative shoes here can we
do did she have a
do you have a
an amendment before you
do you have the amendment no
you don't have the amendment
oh
is there any other comments questions
concerns on the amendment we're talking
about the amendment 0270h
oh no
good
okay
welcome
um
seeing no further comments on the
amendment
i will ask the clerk to call the roll on
house on uh
amendment to house bill 1170h
which is
uh 20220270h
representative green yes
representative osborne
representative brouillard
clerk votes yes representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes
representative mcguire yes
representative wall no
representative talarsky no
representative schuett
no
representative horrigan
representative
no
representative richards no
representative expedia no
representative schultz
no
representative hill yes
9 8 the amendment passes we are now on
to
octopass as amended on house bill 1170.
representative wallace would you like to
speak to your motion
yes thank you briefly although new
hampshire has but one house concurrent
resolution pending the ballot's budget
amendment resolution there are several
pending that are
there are several pending they are the
balanced budget amendment with 27 states
on board presently convention estates
with 17 wolfpack with five and u.s
trimulants with four with a total of 42
states with some type of resolution
pending
that being said it's crucial to have
these guard rails in place prior to the
convention call regardless of your
position on the article 5 process
all right all set thank you
representative wallace um
further comment
representative oregon well basically
just what i said when debating the
amendment the uh
the amendment did not meet the
objections that i present i apologize
for speaking out of turn but
just the fact remains that
if such a convention
came along it would
there would be some sort of enabling act
it would have its own rules so it's not
necessarily going to say that we have
four
members and three three alternates it
could be uh that's i mean that's a
number of congressional
that's the number of u.s reps and
senators have but there's no guarantee
of that it could be something else and
it might even
say how they're going to be appointed
they might not necessarily be appointed
by the legislature might ask for popular
elections i think this
uh
so i think this thing is uh it's
premature and i think it also probably
does not match
what we would actually be asked to do
and there should be ample time
to pass uh to pass an rsa to uh
to
cover this issue and also
also we we if we had to elect the
officials we'd have to make a number of
changes to election law too so um that's
that's why i'm feel silly breezing in
here like this halfway through but i'm i
urge everyone to vote no and on the
ought to pass we're casting no
aspersions representative our
representative wall thank you mr
chairman all al adams we've had this
bill several times before and it's died
i i'm not going to support it thank you
thank you representative wall any
further comments questions
representative wallace thank you mr
chairman actually this
virtually identical bill passed both
chambers
the house and the other body in 2015 it
was subsequently vetoed by the governor
at that point in time both times on
consent so this bill has not been
defeated previously
in his current rendition thank you
representative the record shows that
good
seeing no further comment
we're
good for a vote our rep i will ask the
clerk to call the roll on house bill
1170 ought to pass as
amended representative green yes
representative osborne
representative roulard
house uh the clerk votes yes
representative simon yes
representative folsom yes
representative wallace yes
representative mcguire
representative no
representative tellerski no
representative schuett
no
representative horrigan no
representative nutting wong no
representative richards no
representative expedia no
representative schultz no
representative hill
1170 passes
9 to 8 ought to pass as amended
um
assuming it'll as on the regular
calendar will it be a minority report
seeing none
no
um we'll ask the clerk to reset and then
we'll be on the 1309.
all right opening the exact session on
house bill
1309 i'll tell you now there are five
people signed in in support online
and zero in opposition
um
i would ask representative simon for
a motion
thank you mr chair i would uh move itl
on 1309.
thank you representative simon is there
a second second
representative green seconds house bill
1309 itl
representative simon would you like to
speak to your motion
um
sure once i'm just
so there are a couple different things
with this bill uh real quickly one is
that it invites the senate into a
process on house rules which seems
to not make a lot of sense
um
the other is uh we heard testimony
that most of these things are are added
in by the senate and not by ourselves
um
and so it seems strange to to
do this on the house side uh so with
that i i'd move itl on 1309. thank you
representative simon is there further
comment on house bill 1309
representative expedia
now just given the depth that the budget
trailer bill gets in hb2
and
each individual part i think it would be
worthwhile to
establish you know to study that and
and to create a committee to just take a
look at it and so we'll i'll be voting
no on the uh on an ito
thank you representative expedia anyone
else on house bill 1309
representative simon just real quickly
uh just
um off of representative espida's uh
comments i'm not sure that the
conflict is necessarily on whether or
not we want things to get a public
hearing just for the record i think
i would like to see things get an
adequate public hearing as well just the
the way that the bill itself is
constructed um there are just too many
flaws in it for this to be an
appropriate vehicle to make that happen
so just so just to say that at least as
from my perspective we're on the same
page on that
thank you representative simon any
further comments questions concerns
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the role on house bill
representative greene yes representative
osborne
representative roulard
clerk of ots
representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes representative mcguire
representative wall no
representative tallersky no
representative schuett
no representative horrigan
no
representative
yes
representative richards no
representative expedia no
representative schultz no
representative hill yes
10-7
house bill
um
itl motion passes
10-7 is that right
minority report
no
that takes care of house bill 1309 um
just a couple more here folks uh 1370
um
comes up next 1370.
um i will tell you 42 people spoke
or signed in in
support
one person signed in in opposition
and i am asking for a motion from
representative simon
thank you mr chair i would like to move
itl on hp 1370
representative simon moves itl is there
a second on house bill 1370
itl motion second
second by representative wallace
representative simon would you like to
speak to your motion please
uh yes mr chair thank you um i
understand that there are a lot of
difficulties um
when you run for office as far as time
constraints and responsibilities
um
first off i don't really want to add
another study committee to an already
overburdened study committee
sector
of work for us but
just as a
a general rule
as a business owner i have a hard time
wrapping my head around asking myself
and other people who run businesses to
pay taxes to offer a service that we
ourselves aren't able to
provide for our our own workers
and so
i'm always a little hesitant when we
when we start off this kind of
conversation this way
where we do it at the state level when
the people who will be paying for it
can't necessarily provide it and might
want to provide it further for their own
employees so with that i would move itl
representative simon moves itl uh are
there any other comments questions
representative wall
thank you mr chairman um i
quite honestly was against this to begin
with but then i looked at who the
sponsors were and though we didn't hear
from representative wallner she owns a
couple of
daycare centers here in new hampshire in
concord excuse me
i feel if someone
of that caliber who is at that
reputation that's been in the
legislature a very long time wants to
look at this
and figure out what to do
then it might be worth it we had this
bill last time and we didn't pass it
that doesn't mean that
what some of the sponsors wanted was for
us to have daycare right here in the llb
it means options somewhere around and
what to look at and how to do this so uh
given the fact that we have someone who
owns a couple of daycare centers who
wants to look at this further i'm going
to support this bill
thank you representative while any
further yep representative
i would just like to comment that um
in
in off comments there was a really great
suggestion on how to make sure that we
can support our study committees and so
i hope to see that come forward but i
don't think that that just because we
have a lot of study committees means
that we should not be supporting another
one when there is something as important
as this to look at which is an issue
that really our economy is is relying on
right now so
i'm gonna vote against the itl and in
support of this thank you representative
richards
representative schultz
thank you mr chair i agree with all
the things that my democratic colleagues
have said and i happen
to know that we have more than one
member uh on both sides of the aisle men
and women who have young children that
uh do struggle
with their with their abilities to
attend and and do
uh the work that we do in part because
of concerns around this and
you know i don't think this study
committee is offensive in any way
uh it probably will benefit folks like
the gentle lady from nashua
and i think it's um
you know it's just a study committee
there's no harm in the conversation
thank you representative charles for
representative harrigan um yes i think
i think this committee will help us not
just to figure out
how to handle child care for our own
members and there's more to it than just
you know providing some sort of daycare
or nursery it also may mean how we
how our what our procedures are and how
we meet and when we meet and
also this legislature is uh
gradually getting younger i've been here
14 years i'm 65 years old when i came
here
i think there are hardly any members
there's only a handful of members who
had young children and i think the first
and there's a rep who gave birth i think
my second term a republican from
somersworth who i think had been the
first one first member to give birth
well the first female member many male
members partners had given birth um in
a number of years and now um
now we have uh many many reps who are
raising raising young children so
as a
sort of my generation
i mean i'm planning to be around for a
long time but my generation is starting
to fade from the scene we're either
dying or moving on to other activities
so we are becoming a younger body so i
think we
we should get ahead of this issue and
having a study committee meet this fall
issue report would be a useful first
step so i'll vote for the committee
thank you representative hargan life is
passing us by representative nutting
wong
hi as the representative previously
mentioned from nashua um i did want to
point out what also representative
horrigan's uh mentioned is that child
care options isn't necessarily just
where do we put our kids but making sure
that we schedule or
could be studying when hours are good or
even notices on how like how much time
we give members to find
child care
it's not necessarily not in the scope of
the committee and i would just like to
see this pass so we could get more um so
we could study this i guess yeah thank
you representative netting wong any
further comments
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
a role
representative green yes representative
osborne
representative roulard yes claire class
representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes
representative mcguire
no representative
no
representative oregon
representative
no
representative richard no
representative expedia no
representative schultz
no
representative hill yes
928 will there be a minority report
yes
nutting
wong um
that closes out house bill 1370.
um
we're on to house bill 1486
and i would ask representative nutting
long for a motion
uh yes i motioned to itl hb 1486.
uh representative netting wong moves
itl on house bill 1486
and is there a second
representative wallace
representative netting wong would you
like to speak to your motion
sure
um
what we recognize or while i recognize
that um
we make a lot of sacrifices to be here
sometimes at the cost of our employment
uh this bill is
wild um
um it's we found con like constitutional
issues um the department of health and
services was not particularly excited
about it
um so though i think we all recognize
that we do make sacrifices it's just not
the
way to do it
thank you
thank you representative netting wong
any further comments on
house bill
seeing none i think we're in agreement
um
i will ask the clerk to call the roll on
house bill 1486. representative green
yes representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes representative simon yes
representative folsom yes
representative wallace yes
representative mcguire
representative wall yes
representative talersky yes
representative schuett
yes representative horrigan yes
representative nutting wong yes
representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz no
no no
um
representative hill
yes
okay 16 1
passes 16-1 any objection to consent
none
uh no minority report either right
right
um
house bill 1586
i am
are you set to go yes
house bill
1586 uh i would ask representative
sheehan for a motion
um i move ought to pass mr chair
representative sheehan moves out to pass
representative walls
seconds
um representative sheehan would you like
to speak to it
um no thank you thank you representative
wall
thank you mr chairman i just want to say
that once in a while something really
wonderful and remarkable happens up here
and although the sponsor had good
intentions um we didn't have adequate
testimony and suddenly our house clerk
who took time off from work
um came in and filled us in with the
information we really needed for this
portrait the fact is it will not cost
the state a penny
the money is going to be donated the
portrait will be painted by someone
that's already apparently been chosen
and all that's going to be required of
this legislature is to choose a place to
hang in the state house thank you
thank you representative wall before you
get to that however there is an
amendment uh that's necessary and that
is house
amendment two zero two two
0 3 4 5 h
my name is actually on it but
representative greene
can you move
i move both a pass on the amendment
does everyone have the amendment
no
very short
we can get
we can get copies made um i'll tell you
it's two lines here i'll read it to you
um amend the bill by replacing all after
section one with the following so
everybody looking at section one
it all it says is
a
portrait of wentworth cheswell the joint
legislative historical committee is
authorized to accept a gift of a
portrait of wentworth cheswell and
oversee the hanging of the portrait in
the state house
and the effective date shall take effect
july 1 2022.
so it's
as simple an amendment as we can get but
we will get copies to all of you um
mr chair could you please repeat the
amendment number
no i can't um
mr chair i can i wrote it down
do you want okay ready to do that great
zero two zero two two
dash zero three four five h
sorry zero three four five h okay
um
so we need uh a second thank you
representative expedia seconded um
we
have any further discussion on the
amendment representative expedia i'd
just like to thank the clerk
for for testifying on the bill but also
to offer in this and
for kind of helping us out in the
implementation of this
thank you i think we all join in that um
any further comments i'll ask the clerk
to call a roll on
the amendment to
house bill
1586 representative greene yes
representative osborne
representative roulard
clerk of ots representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes representative mcguire
representative wall yes representative
tallersky yes representative
yes
yes representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz yes
representative hill yes 17-0 amendment
uh whatever number passes
and uh zero three four five h passes and
uh now we are on how to pass
with amendment
um is there any further discussion on
house bill
not seeing none um
clark can call the role representative
greene yes representative osborne
representative brouillard
clerk votes yes representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes representative mcguire
representative wall yes representative
tallersky yes representative
yes
yes representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz yes
representative hill
yes
17-0
i'm going to ask
that we not put this on the consent
calendar
although
the idea is if we don't put it on the
consent calendar
i'm not sure this is the right time
this is going to be an enormous session
that we have coming up
so i'm i'm wondering if we do put it on
the consent and then in in a future date
we do
um a unanimous consent and um we explain
how this all works and where we go yeah
representative mcguire
um
i'm getting i'm getting the shake over
there uh from from uh our house clerk
i i think the idea is that um time is of
the essence here and and if we can
if it's not an early bill just don't
send it to the clerk
yep we could do that
we could do that we can hang on to it
and then do um in the in the next
maybe the next session after we deal
with all of the early bills is that
where house clerk would you like to
speak yep
no we'll talk about it
let's think about it
um
we'll hold it
okay
because it does cry out for uh
conversation on the floor and uh
and we'll do our best to make that
happen i guess i'll leave it at that
um
no consent
representative osborne
it's not a bad idea either but we need
to
who knows when that will be first of all
and secondly we've got a bill that we've
got to do something with but i agree
with you it would be interesting if we
could show it
you could have we could have the
majority leader hold up the little
picture that was on the uh
yeah right right
oh that's right sorry no props you can't
uh
yeah i think it would
be i think it would be
yeah
we'll figure out something here
there's also the option to
put it on the regular calendar but then
special order it to take it up earlier
we'll um we'll have a conversation
um the three of us uh representative
wall rep and the house clerk and i and
we'll
we'll work on something special
fireworks excluded
last bill i'm going to ask this is house
concurrent resolution 9.
i spoke with the prime sponsor on it
really all he wanted out of this was a
um a certificate some recognition
um really didn't need to be filed as a
as a
bill
so
we're already working with the speaker's
office on that
he had one ques one
one suggestion or one request and that
was for us to not kill it
because
by the time the certificate gets there
he doesn't want this person to
be seeing that the committee killed her
or bill so i'm requesting that we um
that we move into someone moves interim
study on this so that it it's not dead
it's it's here and then he can surprise
her with the certificate hopefully she's
not watching
um so moved at any rate
that's uh that's my suggestion uh can i
get a motion on
hcr 9
representative expedia yeah i'll move to
interim study the bill thank you second
representative wallace thank you
doesn't need any further discussion i
think i just did it um
are we
ready to call the role
yes
uh representatives absolutely after this
hmm i have something after this oh yeah
all right jumping ahead of us
representative greene
yes representative osborne yes
representative
yes
clerk motifs
representative simon yes representative
folsom yes representative wallace yes
representative mcguire
representative wall yes
representative talersky yes
representative
yes
yes representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz yes
representative hill
yes
thank you everyone uh representative
speedy you have something yes but not
pertaining to this bill something else
okay so um i have additional amendments
here if anybody needs one for that the
cheswell bill
um
interim study doesn't need yeah we want
we can do that we can put that on
sure so thank you
i wanted to go back to
uh
hb hb1104 um so i
after getting some more consultation on
this bill i realized that hp 1650
extends
to
past the
past biennium so
i wanted to ask if someone would like to
reconsider i would like i would like to
vote to i tell this bill but obviously
so
i need someone on the prevailing side to
i'll move reconsider thank you
representative what's that oh that's
right you don't yeah
representative simon did all right and
i'll i'll support of the second lap
so we are
reconsidering um
1104 is that what it was yes
reconsider
okay you want to grab one we're going to
have to reset here while we get another
form from
our
assistant and i apologize for holding us
up for lunch
yeah representative harrigan i'm the
prime sponsor so i was happy that they
took my idea and improved on it i still
think maybe my wording for the first
part of it is better but they mean the
same thing so i'm uh
i'm happy to go yeah so i okay i like hp
1650 and so this bill is unnecessary
so what we'll have to do is is vote on
reconsideration
and
we will reconsider the vote and so we'll
vote yes on that
um and then
we
the
prevailing motion will be itl and then
we'll
run the role on that
is the bill
representative
representative simon made the motion
um
you know
i had representative wallace
then we have two prevailing side people
and it's going to be ital
well right now we're voting on the
reconsideration
representative simon would you like to
speak to the motion of reconsideration
thank you mr chair i was just trying to
be helpful
okay
i would uh i'd also like to get this on
consent if it's possible so that's the
goal
so um
we get the
we get the commit we got the role for
um environment nag is that what we got
not legislative administration so we
hold up here while uh we get the right
otherwise it would be a lot of done
blank looks when she started calling the
role for
environment and ag people
details details
although we may have people
also serving on environment and ag is
they
yeah there you go
good yep
motion is reconsideration
representative wallace would you like to
speak to the motion of reconsideration
no
you're welcome
good
no further
no further discussion on the motion of
reconsideration on house bill 1104
i will ask clerk to call the roll
representative green yes representative
osborne
representative roulard
clerk votes yes representative simon yes
representative folsom yes representative
wallace yes representative
yes
representative
yes representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz yes
representative hill yes
motion passes we are
we have voted uh to reconsider house
bill 1104 the prevailing motion is itl
is there any discussion
i just want to
yep i just want to apologize
thank you to the clerk for
dealing with dealing with my mistake
no worries uh
seeing no other
yep
seeing no other discussion i'll ask the
clerk to call the role as soon as she's
ready
and i do still have amendments for the
cheswall does anybody need that
got it good
by the way this cheswall bill would have
been an excellent fourth grade
instead of
wouldn't it
teaching moment
good
representative so we have
house bill 1104
no further discussion for the itl motion
um
that i can see so i would ask the clerk
to call the role
representative greene yes representative
osborne
representative roulard yes sir
representative simon yes representative
folsom yes
representative wallace yes
representative mcguire yes
representative wall yes
representative talarsky yes
representative schuette yes
yes
yes representative richards yes
representative expedia yes
representative schultz yes
representative hill yes
17-0 any objections to consent
yahoo
um
we're good i think i think we've set a
new record here for
cleaning off our calendar uh we have
three bills left to exec we're going to
work on amendments for all of those and
there will be another date in the
calendar for a very brief exact session
thank you everyone thank you all our
our
fine substitutes for the day appreciate
it very much
get those blurbs to me as quickly as
they can especially the blurb on
i think on the legislative
1486 is the early bill
do you have this
stipend for legislators
okay so
1486 is
i can't hear you so as soon as you can
get that to us that would be great i
have a question
you